ich könnte einmal die ganze u bahn
vollkosten haltet eure wii kommt meiner
ersten folge dieses gefürchteten
gefürchteten gefürchteten fürchteten
summe ein kleines extra format machen
hier nicht einfach unterschiedliche
kategorien einfüge und was genau daraus
wird weiß ich noch nicht aber wir werden
sehen
also viel spaß und unsere erste
kategorie lautet ich sorge eure
instagram bilder mein ursprünglicher
plan war supertoll is a hat fotos von
euch zu finden dieses hier oder das hier
oder das oder das doch dann ist mir
aufgefallen die post-it fast nur
tierbilder was zur hölle los
ich hoffe du hast ein kondom benutzt
machen wir lieber weiter mit der
nächsten kategorie aktuelle sache nun zu
denen ich etwas sagen werde
auch wenn es keinen interessiert an
manchen deutschen schulen sollen sehr
kurze klamotten verboten werden dazu
eine sehr witzige geschichte meine
cousine hat mich immer dafür so beneide
dass ich mir die nägel lackieren darf
oder meine haare färben darf und so zur
schule gehen darf danach darf das darf
und für mich war das immer ganz normal
arbeiten polnischen schulen darf man
selbst das nicht darf darf aber
eigentlich sollte man ja tragen dürfen
was man möchte oder wozu mama und papa
sein ich kann dazu nur sagen dass ich
selber gar nicht so gerne kurze
klamotten tragen am strand oder im
freibad ist es ja auch ganz normal und
auch völlig in ordnung da fühle ich mich
auch wohl damit aber wenn du dann in der
u-bahn stehst und von einem mann quasi
ausgezogen das mit den blicken
ich kann im strahl kotzen ich könnte
einmal die ganze u bahn folgt kotzen ich
glaube wirklich dass sie denken dass sie
es dürfen nur weil man halt
so aussieht aber gut ich gucke auch in
einem riesigen ausschnitt menschen sehe
ich weiß nicht warum wir sind halt
menschen die gerne sachen gucken sondern
sie halbnackt wind das muss dann im
endeffekt auch jedes mädchen für sich
selbst wissen ob sie es aushalten
diese trägt eine kurze hose
also ich finde eine schuluniform ganz
praktisch wenn ich an meine schulzeit
zurückdenke erinnere ich mich ganz offen
situation wie ich morgens vor dem
kleiderschrank stand 20 minuten 30
minuten nicht wusste was ich tragen soll
man ja besonders cool aussehen möchte
und jeden tag was anderes tragen und da
hätte eine schuluniform mir sehr viel
entspannung gegeben heute richtig
ehrenamtlerin hoffe das ist nochmal
anziehen kann
wo bleibt die nächste kategorie
favoriten favoriten auf jeden fall zwei
serien die ich während erklären kann
einmal eng mit red bull das ist so eine
englische horrorserie dass wir auf alte
englische geschichten und diese ganze
küste schweden zu der zeit steht also
zum beispiel jack the ripper und so
gehen kann ich empfehlen und die zweite
serie stargate online also das ist ein
anime und da geht es um ein videospiel
in dem die leute gefangen sind und ich
will eigentlich auch nicht zu viel
verraten und es ist super und anschauen
lohnt sich
immer wenn ich etwas empfehle mache ich
jetzt so kommen wir zum nächsten thema
geschichten aus der youtube welt wie ich
schon in meinem letzten moment
argumentieren parodiert habe was viele
auch zu kurz banken also wenn es zu kurz
war es ja nur ein kompliment nicht dass
ich so intertainment für unruhe an
keksen und macht eine challenge strauß
meine meinung dazu finde ich nicht cool
und noch eine sache die mir sehr gefällt
future hat seine neue ep rausgebracht
durch ihrem letzten album if you seitz
haben sie mir wieder die nächte geraubt
und ihre ep aufgenommen
wir wurden einer wg deshalb macht sinn
dass die musik spielen und ich dann
nicht schlafen kann weil dies in der
nacht tun weil man ja auch in den achten
sieg spielt aber wenigstens ist eine
gute idee heraus gekommen also energie
haifa frühstück und die könnte ja mal
rein können kommen wir nun zum wetter
anfang der woche sind mit leichten
schauern und gewittern zu rechnen
in der mitte der woche ist es teils
sonnig teils bewölkt zum ende hin wird
es wieder schön danke das wetter putin
präsentiert von passenden thoracic
kommen wir nun zur twitter frage auch
seine schöne kategorie die sich kein
geführt habe ich habe euch auf twitter
gefragt was eure urlaubsziele dieses
jahr sind und das sind eure antworten
wilhelm ich versuche noch nach london zu
kommen ich auch ich war noch die da und
alle davon geschwärmt also erzähl mir
doch mal wie es war mein englischlehrer
vorhat was ist los bei dir warum besucht
und englischlehrer im urlaub bitte nein
es ist nicht vorbei am gerade also ich
meine es nicht ich denke schon beim warm
ist dann muss es doch in dubai
mindestens dreimal so waren seien raus
vor die haustür
ich wünschte viel glück ich habe mich
noch nicht getraut aber du wirst es
packen die sonne hat mich verlassen und
jetzt seht ihr meine wahre gesicht
mein bett du wirst auch zu meinem bett
cool dann können wir vielleicht alle
dort treffen portugal
wir wollten dies ja eigentlich auch nach
portugal aber leider klappt das alles
nicht sooo wegen videos und games körben
zu hause noch familie besuchen und noch
vieles mehr
und deswegen bleiben wir zu hause dieses
jahr macht sie ganz viele von euch und
fahre nach balkonien leute ihr seid so
witzig was würde ich tun
ihr seid alles für mich ich liebe euch
wie burger meine fantasiewelt
danke für diesen beitrag ich fand ihn
super das daumen schön aussehen muss die
augen zu und stellst dir vor du wärst in
einem schuhkarton warum fällt mir das
denn jetzt grade als erstes ein
also online gezwungen ist immer so braun
weil ich einen kaffee trinker bin ganz
furchtbar reicht trinkl die habe ich
vier tassen am tag ganz viele schreiben
hier immer dass meine zunge so braun ist
und ja bevor ich ein videodreh trinke
ich meistens ein café und dann denke ich
auch nicht darüber nach wie die zähne zu
putzen das tut mir leid ich liebe kaffee
so sehr so sehr wie ich euch liebe und
ich burger liebe so sehr liebe dich
kaffee ich hoffe euch hat die erste
folge vom sommer noch gefallen nächste
woche gibt's dann die nächste und mal
gucken was soll ich find's cool ich mag
die zusammenstellung von ihnen sachen
ich mag geräten
was muss sie aussieht wenn man böse
guckt und an dass hier mit hochzieht